scored from the point Edmonton getting production
from its back end recently kulak had a goal in
the win over the Flames as well both teams
coming off wins over Calgary here's Kanye
for sh back to hollow and his one-handed chip
attempt disappears into the midsection with
and he makes a nice little play hkin and all
over him here's that chance by Kane early on
beautiful pass across by himman on the tape
and he has a good look and then the legs of
hollow didn't really move too much wanted to
take that Center position away and that was
exactly why trying to take those cross
passes through turnover newon Hopkins
unable to bury it and it was flicked wide
by amander K aggressive pinch Here by Cody
CeCe but here's the chance it'll chip into
the Zone Evans has had some success here as
wedw goes out to play it it bounces right
off the aggressive hman on that chance the
Stars almost handed the Oilers one and Newen
Hopkins unable to finish Hyman rushes in from
the right hand side this was another good unit
against Calgary but here's duain the other way
scores M duchaine backand afterwards good reaction
by Wedgewood to get back across and make the save
right here is where CCE comes down to chip off
the wall is one and it's do shame with the shot
Darnell nurse takes the two-on-one away leaves
the shooter to the goal tender and he goes was
right under that but a nice chip off the wall
by marshman you know that def's coming down
aggressively under the pressure make the play Last
by booster sa W didn't know where the rebound was
and that time with both the blocker and glove get
him up high take it away but can't handle it and
then Brown pounces on look at that trying to float
one in front no one home easily sprinting back the
other way was EO got a tough off off behind him
but then it's back he can't stick and he ties it
theander C stays hot that's his
third a good clear out of the zone you can see
atol gets that puck first he just wants to flip
it off but it goes off the back ofman this might
be offside I think hman might have crossed the
line before this goes in potentially looks like
they want to drop the puck and signal up it's
a good goal so obviously not as nen Hopkins that
blows a wheel picks up the loose Pucket goes right
through that tour through western Canada they'll
play in Vancouver on Saturday night Edinson plays
host to Nashville for a Saturday mat that one for
Bard run one right off the pipe he's like listen
I'll let this go a little bit until I have to put
my bucket back on here's the backtrack I talked
about on that wall that pressure by McDavid leads
to a quick pass by Robertson good sh by line yeah
crowd loves having G back he's made a couple
of good play tonight hin with a giveway and
now brober skates the center didn't get much
on the dump it h wires it ahead and all of a
sudden three on one it's cross qu timer score Joe
Peli buries it and it's 21 Dallas he goes to the
backand though forc to the backand a little bit he
just can't make the play makes the change but that
leaves a three-on-one the other way and it's just
a beautiful pass across for a one-time p who has
a terrific record no active player scored more
points against Evon than Joe pavelski he opens
up he knows it's coming and really no chance I
didn't mean that respectfully you finish your
check cuz everybody says you have to finish your
check there's other guys that hit the hurt Kane
hits the hurt here's Tyler s again trying to set
a redirected and Skinner made an acrobatic denial
off his own man the that goes off the skate
this is a good reaction by steuart Skinner
just tracking the puck and then look at this has
to flash the glove back against the great scored
a 16th career shorthanded goal last night against
calg McDavid to new Hopkins saucered back to Bard
trle Bard one timer and that went off the post
that's two was up on edge and he still got all of
that Rings the post this time vital penalty kill
here Lou trailing 2-1 Dallas pokes it on net the
rebound is tucked home by rope hints and the Stars
need just 21 seconds on the power play to extend
to a 31 lead for hints that's his fourth here
it is here on the entry you'll see hining kind
of drop at the Speedy hints with a ton of speed
at the line he makes a backhand pass and maybe
that's what they're looking at but I think it was
on side and then fuddle yourself to the net but
if you watch this this was kind of a broken play
it goes in inside it's the stick of pavelski to M
over to nurse shot tipped wide by hin and rebound
g a blast the save rebound lwood scolling stop at
a terrific one point blank and Ryan McLoud cannot
believe it again the Oilers back on the attack a
shot to a screen G had it kicked away now McDavid
dancing centering and that was an open Leon drle
who just couldn't take super clean contact with
that pocket Robertson ahead open Peli centers
and tapped home by rope hence and another example
of Edmonton a near Miss at one end and a Dallas
Stars conversion at the other against a team
like this this is the chance goes off the skage
drle can't finish put it send the transitional
play once again to the Dallas Stars you can see
thatle kind of come down then he backs out but
I mean nobody's coming back aggressive enough it
was McDavid that eventually gets back but just too
much time off the rush outnumbered and a beautiful
pass across by hint and dug out by Warren Fogle
that's around H Fogle short handed back no and yet
another missed opportunity in front H theway Point
black and Wedgewood kicked it out and Marchman two
big guys here's that blast up the ice speed wise
for Fogle looking like 97 a bit goes to the back
hand and just rolls off the end of his stick he
was under pressure his pressure sorry his Hast
can in continue then this one bobbles off the and
there were a handful of games last year like this
one except in Reverse where Edmonton seemingly
was able to pounce on every opportunity tries
to Center play again Kan just had a stick tied
up by Wyatt Johnson how many times have we seen
that where it looks like it's going to be a clean
look there's a big hit by Nur and marman gives him
a long hard look he might come back here as he
looks at the bench and nobody's there s g just
faked him out of his equipment kak rebound back
into [Applause] Wedgewood Kan welcome back to
Edmonton wcft talked about stimulating the
bottom six getting something going finding
some different people producing this is a big goal
and you can see the excitement on this bench not
only for G who had a long road back to get to
the National Hockey League after a couple hip
surgeries double hip surgery had to recover
from but he drives in and just jams this one
home on Wedgewood look at the traffic in front
of him here that puck bouncing around you have
to find the lose Puck and he does Kan a steel
dis lose score D again that's two for Sam and
the Oilers are within four to three it's the work
by Kane off the face off here you're going to see
him punch through one p gobling punch stays with
it rolls off of his stick and that little slap
out of the reach of rope hits we told you that it
didn't feel like a three-goal game well now it's
not and it's hard to explain that when you're
looking at the score but they've continued to
press F in front that was ticked on that by
mlod and a save by Wedgewood of entertainment
D to the to no it stays out rebound D title
he's got it he centers deflected off escate
30 seconds to play McDavid to three the on
net ww leaves hard Rim HW and Pa and the Stars
survive boy I'll tell you
what a sequence at the end
here in a long long shift 49 shots
50 Now They just added another one